hey Bill O'Reilly dot-com Premium
Members welcome to the no spin news on
audio today because I'm out here on
Eastern Long Island soaking up the end
of the summer and we'll be back on video
on Monday but this week will be audio
unless something you know explodes so we
got a lot to talk to you about today and
and and it's very interesting first of
course is the president speech last
night in Afghanistan we have you have
two choices in Afghanistan you can leave
and the predictable consequence of
leaving would be that the Taliban would
take over most of the country Kabul
might be able to hold out Bagram Air
Force Base outside of Kabul where the US
troops are based that would hold out but
primarily the Taliban would run the
country so that's what would happen
there's no real debate on that and then
the Taliban would let Isis and al-qaeda
and every other terrorist group do what
they want
so you'd be right back to where you were
in 2000 so that's option number one get
out we did the best we could it was a
noble endeavor which it was but the
Afghan people are not strong enough to
fight their own battles and they never
will be okay so that that's the option
that President Trump rejected what he
accepted was a ongoing presence like
Korea but with bullets flying we're
we're there and NATO you know they're
there to but not to the extent that we
are with about ten twelve thousand
American troops and then we're basically
fire fighters so when the Taliban pops
up we whack them all and back and we
keep the country out of the hands of the
Taliban so that that's the option that
President Trump is embraced you said
okay we're willing to spend the money
and you know at that level you're
talking Oh 50 60 deaths a year
as a chopper crash or something and
maybe 300 wounds
you know it's substantial it's not
trivial but that would keep the country
in place now I'd like to talk to
Secretary of Defense Madison he knows
more than anybody I'd like to see look
do you have any hope at all the Afghan
army and police services can control
their country or is it just not ever
gonna happen I'd like to you know have
that conversation with Maddox but Maddox
isn't gonna certainly answer those
questions but he knows mattis knows now
I was
you may remember over there in
Afghanistan and the primitive nature of
the country is just startling it's
tribalism with with Islam driving
behavior and depending on where you are
in the religious scale there are some
liberal Islamists and some very very
conservative Islamists that dictates how
you behave the Taliban are
fundamentalists they're gonna come in at
Sharia law there was one thing that
struck me when I was driving into Kabul
from the airport and we flew in on a big
transport plane and it was no lights and
a contrary member sitting in the cockpit
telling a pilot we close by and he goes
yeah we're gonna land in 15 minutes I
looked down I said well there's a light
there's no he goes well they'd all have
electricity only the big cities so it
was like black I thought we were over
the ocean but anyway you get into a
primitive society and I was riding into
Kabul in a car with my bodyguards and
and I said stop for a moment a car
stopped and and on the side of the
street was this was a cement wall with
these iron round things and what looked
like rust all over the place and I said
what's that that caught my eye because
that's where and then the bodyguard said
to me that's where the Taliban
would put people for public floggings if
they committed adultery if they were gay
or any like that they they shackle them
into these iron cast-iron around things
up against the concrete wall and beat
them and and and so everybody could see
it and then that that's the kind of
society the Taliban impose so President
Trump you know made the case said look
we got to stay there because we can't
have this 9/11 situation again where you
have a breeding ground and training
ground for Isis and al Qaeda so you have
to do it most Americans I think agree
with that even though it's frustrating
they say it's the longest war in
American history but yeah we're not
really fighting the war if we were
fighting a war we did invade Pakistan
and kill all the Taliban is hiding up in
the northwest quadrant and what are you
gonna do with Pakistan I mean he says
that you know they're gonna get tougher
on them but you know it's okay but
they're not gonna the Pakistani
government's chaotic there's a lot of
Islamists in the government some people
want to root out the terrorists some
people don't
there's assassinations all over the
place the countries out of control they
have a nuke so there's only so much we
can do over there
I'm not expecting you know great strides
by Pakistan to fight the Taliban it's
not going to do it so very frustrating
the rest of the world doesn't care about
Afghanistan they don't really care about
al-qaeda or Isis they basically trying
to avoid being killed but are they gonna
you know help us no it's all of us
always lost very frustrating but I don't
think the American people were angry
with this speech last night it was good
to see President Trump being a president
rather than involved in all this crazy
stuff all right so the president travels
tonight to Phoenix Arizona 10:00 p.m.
Eastern time big rally he's got plenty
of supporters in Arizona that's why he's
going the Governor of Arizona you know I
was a conservative guy Ducey Doug Ducey
he's not going to be at the rally but he
will
Griet Trump the two Republican senators
don't like him flake and McCain there
won't be anywhere near there I do
believe that President Trump will pardon
Sheriff Arpaio is convicted of violating
federal law in immigration by having his
local guys do federal work I think that
our pile will be will be pardoned
tonight that'll be a big headline
tomorrow everybody be screaming about it
you can expect a stem-winder from a
president Trump you will vent and then
our piyo will get the pardon all right
now let's change gears a little bit and
tell you about a story it's extremely
extremely troubling this far left
intimidation of sponsorship is out of
control and they did that to me Media
Matters and there's a whole bunch of
these groups so the latest victim is a
group called jihad watch alright and
jihad watch is an organization that
warns the world about the dangers of
Muslim fundamentalism and terrorism well
a group ProPublica funded by George
Soros has targeted jihad Watch and its
director Robert Spencer and they've
convinced PayPal to ban any donations to
jihad watch is what these people do they
threaten PayPal or Amazon or and you
know any of that
ProPublica is is just an arm of this
crew that attacks people with whom they
disagree so they're threatening Amazon
Newsmax PayPal for maintaining
partnerships with jihad watch not in the
sense that they're editorially partnered
up they're not they just allow donations
to flow in so let's bring in Robert
Spencer who's the director as I
mentioned of jihad watch so this is a
surprise you right I mean you've been
under fire for a long time as being
anti-muslim your group
correct yeah but that in itself is just
a tactic to try to get it shut down I'm
no more anti-muslim than foes of the
Nazis during World War two were anti
German it's just a canard to oppose
jihad terror is not hateful or bigoted
but the Southern Poverty Law Center has
at eight groups list and they put us on
it a few years ago as they put on many
legitimate conservative groups that have
perfectly reasonable opinions we don't
advocate for violence we don't call for
vigilante action we don't smear innocent
people none of these things but the
Southern Poverty Law Center's hate group
list is full of legitimate groups that
just dissent from the hard left line and
after charlottesville groups like Pro
Publica and other Soros funded
organizations are putting pressure on
advertisers and social media platforms
to shut us all out without ever
examining well wait a minute is this
list really reliable are we really hate
groups no of course we're not so most
people don't know what your group does
why with the Southern Poverty Law Center
and I do agree that this this group is
now a far left advocacy group that's
what it's become why would they object
to you if you're just basically raising
alarm at Tara well you know it's been
going on for years that I I can remember
the very first time I was actually on a
show on MSNBC with Ibrahim Hooper of the
Council on american-islamic relations
and I quoted some statistics from a
survey that was conducted by a Muslim
Sheikh saying that 80% of the mosques in
the United States were teaching
extremism and Hooper in response said
Spencer's a hate monger and I was sort
of stunned because I thought well wait a
minute you didn't answer the problem
about the survey you just said that I
was a hate monger but that is the tactic
that they use and they've convinced to
the left these Islamic advocacy groups
like care they've convinced to the left
that to oppose jihad terror to speak
about the motivating ideology of the
jihad terrorists and how they use the
texts of Islam to make recruits among
peaceful Muslims but all that is hate
and they charge that of course they've
been trying to shut us down for a year
as well because they don't want honest
discussion of these issues how do you
see the Prophet Muhammad
well Muhammad you know obviously he's
the revered figure in Islam and the
problematic aspect of him I wrote a
biography of Muhammad a few years ago
the truth about Muhammad and if you look
at the earliest Islamic texts about his
life they do show that he's leading
campaigns of war he's calling upon
people to assassinate his enemies he did
marry the nine year old girl when he's
54 and so when you have that and he's
held up in the Quran as the excellent
exist well the one that Muslims should
imitate that causes a whole lot of
problematic behavior among Muslims
worldwide thinking that they're
imitating Muhammad they're doing
something that's good when they're
actually abusing girls and committing
warfare against unbelievers and
oppressing Jews and so on but if you are
going to use Muhammad as a negative
example
wouldn't that demonize all Muslims in
the world even the moderate Muslims who
believe in Islam believe that the
Prophet was the direct conduit to Allah
even though these things did happen way
back when so wouldn't they have a point
that basically by pointing this out
about the Prophet and I don't know
whether he reformed or whether he was
different at the end of his lie I don't
know but if you're going to say that
Muhammad did was a warmonger and was
marrying nine-year-old girls you know
that pretty much puts everyone who
believes in Islam in a bad spot does it
not only if they're not willing to
confront the problematic aspects of that
my dear friend tache bhasayate who
passed away a few years ago he was a
Muslim reformer a genuine Muslim
reformer who called for a general
revaluation of Muhammad's status as the
excellent example among Muslims and said
look there are these aspects of
Muhammad's life and career that these
jihadis are exploiting that child
abusers are exploiting that oppressors
of women are exploiting we have to be
honest about that and work for genuine
reform by finding some way to mitigate
the literal importance of these texts
and so I think that
Muslims who follow in the footsteps of
Josh bhasayate are exemplary individuals
and I support them 100% it is not in the
least T Muslims to oppose the
justification of religious warfare and
the justification of child abuse and so
on by that is is done by pointing to
Islamic texts okay I get I get the
subtlety of the argument and but you
know that in this world you're either
you know for us or against us and and
then you and your group have been saying
well you're anti Muslim because you
attack the Prophet and you know if you
put that message out the far-left even
in fact the prophet bill I just say what
he did I understand he is Muhammad is
based on sources that are written by
Muslims this is within Islamic tradition
these things were held up and they
report that I SIA his nine year old
bride was nine years old when he
consummated the marriage this is not
something that I wrote or found in some
dusty corner it's in mainstream islamic
sources that go back to the time of
Muhammad all right but it's you you know
it's a complicated emotional issue I'm
not sticking up for the attacks on jihad
watch I'm trying to understand basically
how the far left is embracing trying to
shut you down I mean I don't know yeah I
don't understand that at all even if
they disagree with your characterization
of Mohammed and they are objecting to
the strong tone you're taking against
Muslims who revere Mohammed even if they
do you certainly have a right to print
and say what you want and so why are
they trying to destroy you yeah the
texts say what they say I mean I think
that the left has a huge moral blind
spot when it comes to Islam that
feminists suddenly stop talking about
women's rights when they see the
institutionalized oppression of women
under Islamic law the Quran says if
there's a woman from whom you fear
obedience then beat her and we don't
hear from feminists about that and why
not same thing with the old test
you can pull out a lot of stuff in the
Old Testament that's pretty grisly about
the things are dead letters where is it
with Quran these things are being acted
upon now some are considered to be part
of the live religion okay so now they've
succeeded in getting paypal to
disassociate itself on a business plane
with you what can I get letters like
doesn't what come what can regular
people do if anything to protect your
right to operate freely well the thing
is we have to recognize in the first
place that there is a concerted effort
to silence and stigmatize demonize and
absolutely marginalize every voice not
form to the leftist line right and so we
have to stand up to it paypal actually
got inundated with protests from people
who support our work and they they
turned around and they just reinstated
me not long ago the thing is I'm not
going back yeah but I'm not going back
to them because I know what they are now
and we have to vote with our feet and
show these people that they can't just
make us jump through their hoops and
conform to their political lines but you
shouldn't though I mean it can a case be
made a mr. Spencer that because PayPal
did finally do the right thing that
maybe you should do business with them
and say look you know they came around
they they listened to our point of view
and you don't accept them back I think
you have a very good point there
actually and I'll think about that I
just don't want to reinforce the idea
that these services should be withheld
or gets applied based on one's
conformity to the leftist political line
no I understand but I think that that in
in this charged era that anybody who
does the right thing should be rewarded
because look Media Matters attacked me
and in the next few weeks we're gonna
you know have some pre startling
information about that and the sponsors
basically said look you know we're not
gonna we're gonna pull out of the
O'Reilly Factor because we don't want
the grief we don't know what happened we
don't really care what happened
we use don't want the grief same thing
with Ivanka Trump's clothing line and
Nordstrom same thing all right we just
don't want the grief so we're gonna just
advertise someplace else when a company
says you know what we'll take the grief
because it's wrong what's happening I
think they should be rewarded so I'm
glad you're gonna take a run another
look at it but regular folks I mean it's
about awareness which is why we're doing
a segment today with you that these
people are now attacking as you said
anyone with whom they disagree on any
issue and trying to silence them and
hurt them as much as they can but again
what can regular Americans do other than
rallied to the cause of the people who's
being attacked well I think also we have
to expose the people that are doing this
that this ProPublica organization this
is not a news service no and shouldn't
be treated as such and these people need
to be revealed for what they are I'm not
talking about any kind of illegal
activity or something I just mean that
in the court of public opinion they need
to be exposed for what they really are
which is hard left propagandists and
actual fascists trying to shut down and
intimidate people who disagree with them
yeah but I mean it's not going to be
done by the mainstream media because
they sympathize with pearl public as you
know Oh certainly yeah right so thank
you Miss bad they published the CNN
published the Southern Poverty Law
Center hate list which includes me and
so many other legitimate groups right
after the Charlottesville attack and
said here are the hate groups in your
area that's like printing a big target
on my back yeah all right mr. Spenser
cheapest and foreigner what happens we
appreciate you coming on in and I do
agree that and it's why I'm doing these
segments that this is a horrible problem
in America a horrible problem whereas
you got is getting work right the far
left they're organized they have
millions and millions of dollars and
they are going after anybody with whom
they disagree all right in the other
news that I want you to know about Army
sergeant Bowe Bergdahl's decided to be
tried by a judge not a military jury on
charges that he endangered comrades by
deserting in Afghanistan a trial and
many of you are very interested in that
is going to commend
in October but you know it's been
postponed so many times that yeah
nothing anything had happened you know I
don't know how Bergdahl gets out of this
you know because guys were hurt
searching for him after he deserted
that's the fact I don't know how he gets
out of it all right how about the the
IRS scandal under President Obama
remember in my interview with him he
told me there was an asset of evidence
that anybody in the IRS targeted
conservative groups that turned out not
to be true but nothing happened however
now a judge
Reggie Walton US District Court in DC
has ordered the IRS to provide more
information about groups that were
targeted and who targeted them from
within the IRS so this is because of
private lawsuits not government
watchdogs all right so private lawsuits
and again it's run by groups that that
are interested in in the welfare of this
country and this is Judicial Watch
Judicial Watch the good group so they
sued and now a judge said to the IRS you
better come up with more stuff we know
what's out there we want to see it so
we're following that story as well
marijuana everybody's a high on
consolation as halle notes one sang want
free pot legalized pot pot for meds pot
for everything well if you are a heavy
pot smoker
research shows that you are in danger of
hypertension study in a European Journal
of preventive cardiology so the more pot
you smoke the more hyper tense you will
be which kind of goes against a mellow
aspect of this I'm not a drug guy as you
all know and I don't think running
around a state of inebriation is good
and can lead to anything good I know I
know a lot of you disagree and that's
good I'm glad you do but you know
there's a lot of downside to smoke at
pot all the time and drinking all the
time
okay all right let's get to the mails we
have some good letters here Wendy a kapa
throne hips which Massachusetts Ipswich
north of Boston on the coast if you go
there go to Woodman's if switch clams
Woodman's in Ipswich legendary hey bill
I became a premium member tonight
because I need your help my 24 year old
son and I had a political debate over
the Nazi group in Virginia told him
everyone has a First Amendment right as
long as they're peaceful my son said the
Nazi group has no rights we should have
zero tolerance and lying in the protests
in any way well I mean look when do you
uh score a point to the court ruling the
judge allowed it and under our
Constitution there aren't exceptions as
long as you're peaceful you could say
what you want as long as it's not
threatening or put anybody in a position
of being in any kind of danger can't do
that mark Bradenton Florida
Donald Trump is a daughter married to a
Jewish man I also believe he is a Jewish
grandson that's true appears to be on
excellent terms with all these family
members when visiting Israeli visited
shrines and synagogues and observe
proper dressing customs these actions
speak for themselves and they do not
connote any neo-nazi or KKK sympathy
very good mark good letter I think it's
right on your letter really is very very
good
Estelle in Decatur Georgia a bill why
can't you say the ante for out are bad
people you know I don't like the extreme
elements of that crowd but I don't know
if it's smart or fair to say everybody
who's protesting against so-called
fascism is a bad person I you know I
don't know if that's I think that might
be going a little bit too far but I
certainly don't like anybody who is
using anti Fah to do bad things I mean
that's despicable Ida Kissimmee Florida
initially bill I disagree with your
analysis of president Trump's era was
the inclusion of an tifa's violence
alongside white supremacy not her Dems
or mainstream media condemned and efis
tactics
seemed unbalanced and unfair as they
criticize the president's they've been a
violence on both sides but as I listened
closely to your no spin news tonight I
understand your explanation and now
agree I've studied the history of the
Nazis which is far-reaching in its evil
the historical evil of Nazism and the
infestations of the end of a group
cannot be scaled equally okay very very
good Ida I'm glad I convinced you I
don't like the anti-fog Rupe by the way
I don't think that they are looking at
the country in a fair way so I want
everybody know that but I appreciate you
you know taking my words and analyzing
it that's what we'd like to see and
that's why this audience on Bill
O'Reilly calms probably the most
sophisticated audience politically in a
country Nancy Anderson Chester South
Carolina many of the Confederate
monuments erected throughout the south
were by communities that lost so many
sons fathers and loved ones in the Civil
War few of the Fallen where every
returned to given a proper burial and
few could afford an indigent Walker so
the ones left behind raise money for one
monument to honor the dead that's an
interesting point Nancy now honoring the
Confederate dead who fought for a cause
that was unjust but did they know that
probably not most of them were teenagers
many of them were illiterate so I mean I
think you really have to step back here
and let history be displayed Connie
Orlando Florida just renewed my
subscription even though it was only 119
days old
I want killing England as soon as it's
hot off the press we have all of your
books and have given many us gifts well
if you do become or re-up Bill O'Reilly
com premium membership you get killing
England free it is now unbelievably
relevant because of the statue stuff and
Martin Dugard and I tell you exactly how
George Washington Thomas Jefferson and
Benjamin Franklin behaved who they were
as people so you can now know the truth
of
about them and evaluate their lives in
totality this is so important so I got a
big break as I wrote in the message of
the day today about the Statue pulling
down stuff killing England you know
they're coming after Washington and and
Jefferson the far left they're coming
after them they want to just wipe out
all of our our history and start over in
their vision Columbus Scott is getting
down all right so good Connie I'm ledger
with us and thanks for the letter Garry
Moore Prescott Valley Arizona bill
thoroughly enjoying your daily nose spin
news I recently renewed my premium
membership was happy to get killing
England free keep up the great work
okay so we're we're moving on that front
and I'll be doing a lot of publicity for
killing England and it's really good
you'll love it I think if you like the
other killing books you really like it
grace is oohara La Palma California just
finished the day the world with nuclear
excellent book also read killing the
Rising Sun found there was much to be
learned about that time my paternal
grandparents and the son were interned
my father took us to Clearfield Utah
read many books over the year about
World War two in Japan's part in it but
all of the books that you've written a
mr. O'Reilly put together stuff that I
did not know well you know I'm grace the
internment wasn't correct but again it
was done out of public safety hysteria
and when you read killing the Rising Sun
you you'll know why everybody was
hysterical
Kelly Galbreath Grand Rapids Michigan a
bill just finished watching the killing
Reagan and killing Lincoln movies on
Amazon Prime I'm wondering if the movies
are exactly what the books are about
they were very good all the movies
killing Lincoln killing Kennedy killing
Jesus and killing Reagan all four were
excellent and they stayed within the
parameters of the book and no nonsense
or craziness okay so I'm glad you get
them on Amazon Prime and we're working
on some movies down the lane about the
other
books so we'll let you know okay so if
you want to reach me it's bill at Bill
O'Reilly calm or the message boards
Twitter followers about 2,200,000 at
Bill O'Reilly we've got a lot of fun
stuff in addition to serious stuff on
Twitter and the word of the day do not
and this is an easy one if you don't
know this one
then you really have to start on your
vocabulary do not be a buffoon be uff
oon and if you know where the urchins
ask them if they know what buffoon means
when writing to Bill O'Reilly dot-com
alright tomorrow we'll have audio again
and I'm savoring every last day of the
summer I hope you are too
thanks for being premium members and
we'll talk again soon